[Music]
in a market in Myanmar vendors display
wares you won't find at your local
market rows of bear paws and
gallbladders big cat teeth and one of
the most expensive items a dismembered
tiger penis Karl Amon is a swiss born
conservation activist and photographer
by trade through his photographs and
website he spent the bulk of his career
shedding light on issues such as the
illegal trade in animal meat in Africa
recently he traveled to mullah a town in
Myanmar formerly Burma along the border
with China even after nearly 20 years of
documenting the worldwide animal trade
nothing could have prepared him for what
he found there this is probably the
worst example I've seen anywhere else in
terms of live animals in terms of meat
Bazin too much today but I've seen a lot
more many illegally traded species will
end up in traditional Chinese medicines
the use of such medicines is said to
date back thousands of years and has
played a major role in the depletion of
species like tigers rhinos and Asian
bears and the demand for them shows no
signs of slowing down
globally the trade in wildlife is a
multi-billion dollar business and it's
booming but nowhere else in the world is
it booming more than in Asia
experts say China is the premier
consumer in the illegal wildlife market
while some of the animals body parts
will end up as souvenirs most will be
used to make Chinese medicines or will
be eaten in exotic animal restaurants
conservation groups like the World
Wildlife Fund know the threat to
wildlife all too well the thing is it's
this large scale industrial extraction
of wildlife it's almost like wildlife
mining anything that can be captured
anything that can be traded is being
sucked out of these countries and it's
going to these consumer markets mom
lives close proximity to China makes it
an ideal trading place for wild animals
tourists easily cross the border into
Myanmar filling up on their grizzly
finds but the time spent at a bear bile
farm outside of Mong la left the deepest
impression on among the bile milked
through a permanent catheter placed in
the bear stomach is taken from Asian
black bears
it's then used in Chinese medicine this
is this bear bile farm in Hmong land
it's really about the worst animal
welfare scenario I have ever encountered
I mean this is not the question of
survival of some hunters it's a question
of really commercial business trying to
make the fast buck all while called
bears so no excuse as far as Chinese are
concerned you know what's even worse
this time is the fact that they're now
interrupted heads against the cage is a
lot of them have their heads chopped off
from disrupting these bears and many
other wildlife species found in the
markets are protected from traffic
through societies or the Convention on
International trade of endangered
species both China and Myanmar are
signers of the Convention yet many of
their citizens show flagrant disregard
for the agreement and there's been
little enforcement by the respective
governments along the border more bears
are kept in tiny cages awaiting the day
when they will be killed for meat or die
due to sickness the illegal wildlife
trade is said to be worth billions of US
dollars each year in Southeast Asia
alone for threatened species the
wildlife trade is a massive problem many
species like tigers mountain gorillas
and rhinos are simply disappearing
illegal wildlife trade is having a major
impact upon species in Asia wildlife is
being taken from its home in the forest
transported very quickly to consumer
markets and being consumed at an
incredible rate there are no checks and
balances and controls in place in many
places to stop this we are really
concerned that we're going to see some
empty forests for the future there may
be forests left but every no wildlife
left
although the Myanmar and Chinese
governments have taken some steps in the
past to protect species captured for the
wildlife trade without greater pressure
from the international community
some experts remain in doubt as to how
much more these governments will do to
remedy the problem
[Music]